walking with dinosaurs I think a better
title for this movie would be walking
out of walking with dinosaurs because
that's what I wanted to do so bad
walking with dinosaurs is a new film
that is supposed to basically teach kids
about dinosaurs you know there are
certain moments in this movie where a
dinosaur will be running or flying and
they'll actually freeze the frame and
it'll say Tyrannosaurus Rex carnivore
now watching the trailer for this movie
I could tell that it was a little bit
different like the marketing company and
the directors in the studio or whoever
was trying to hide certain things
because they show dinosaurs sort of
talking you know they would cleverly cut
their mouths to look like they were
saying words but I knew that this just
not what it is because otherwise there
would be a shot of a dinosaur going
hello I'm a dinosaur rawr that was dumb
there wasn't that shot in the trailer so
I was like I bet you this is just like a
Milo and Otis narration type thing
member Milo and Otis that movie with the
cat and the dog and they were friends
and they want on an adventure but it was
narrated they weren't actually having
the mouse moving that's what this movie
is like the dinosaurs will be walking
around and you'll hear Justin Long or
John Leguizamo as a bird saying various
things and while the trailers are trying
to convince you that this is a cool
movie where you can watch dinosaurs in
their habitat being awesome it's really
just an educational film for very young
children it's a kids documentary that's
meant to teach them things except it
doesn't really teach them anything
except some dinosaur names and there's
this very beat you over the head like
message about family and how everyone
has to stick together and how little boy
dinosaur has a crush on a little girl
dinosaur and how pop song montages
apparently go with prehistoric times and
how current modern-day phrases like
worst migration ever apparently were
what dinosaurs thought back then but my
main flaw of this moving the thing that
I could not get over is that it's
completely conflicted with itself it's
trying to teach kids about dinosaurs and
family but it feels the need to use
excessive poop and puke jokes to make
kids not bored apparently because they
think that if a character doesn't step
in some poopy every other scene
aren't going to enjoy it so we have one
aspect of this film that is trying to be
educational but you got this other
aspect that's pandering to kids today
expecting that they're not going to be
able to enjoy a movie unless somebody
steps in some dinosaur poop or gets
puked on every couple scenes there's
also this one scene that really got
under my skin where this dinosaur falls
into a river and Justin long as the
dinosaur goes I dove John Leguizamo as
the bird is like no I don't think so I
don't think so he's like yeah I did dive
and he's like no I don't really think so
let's take a look at that again then
they literally rewind the footage and
rewatch it again and lays like yep yeah
you fell in the river and he's like I
guess you're right I did fall in the
room I mean there's like a two minute
sequence dedicated to that you want to
know how they could have saved this
entire movie take every single bit of
the juvenile childish poop puke fart
narration out of this movie just remove
all of it and just show the dinosaurs
being dinosaurs this movie would have
been perfect for the Discovery Channel
it would have been awesome because the
3d animation is actually very good in
the 3d is terrific and that is by far
the biggest plus of this movie but it's
filled with this needless juvenile humor
that does not mesh with the educational
thing that it's trying to go for as well
I mean the film even opens with Carl
urban driving his car and his punk kid
who has like his hood up and he's like I
don't like digging up dead things that's
not what I do and Karl Urban is like oh
you should like it it's fun I'm Dredd
and bones I'm a badass why my in this
movie I don't know hmm and then a bird
also voiced by John Leguizamo just flies
one of the cars like hey kid let me tell
you the story about the olden days and
the kids like wow you can talk but his
mouth isn't even moving it's like
narration so it's like the kid has some
kind of telepathy with the bird look I
know this movie isn't aimed at me it's
not made for me it's made for kids but
the fact that I can as an adult realize
that this is just a bunch of people
trying to teach some kids some stuff
about dinosaurs but thinking that
they're not smart enough to watch a
movie unless there's poop and puke and
fart every other scene it's dumb okay
it's not funny it's not very clever and
as good animation and that is it I'm
gonna give walking with dinosaurs a
d-minus not a good movie don't check it
out you probably weren't going to anyway
though guys thanks as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck my nice